liebe Leute dieses Video hier ist etwas
anders als die meisten ich habe sehr
lange drauf gewartet und ich freue mich
wirklich mega aber eins nach dem anderen
dieser YouTube Kanal hier ist gerade
acht Jahre alt geworden kaum zu glauben
aber das erste Video auf Dr Watson habe
ich im September 2015 hochgeladen damals
noch in meinem Wohnzimmer in der
Studentenbude über die Jahre haben immer
mehr von euch diese Videos hier gefunden
den Kanal abonniert und zugeschaut und
dafür bin ich jeden Tag mega dankbar ich
habe irgendwann erste Anfragen bekommen
ich bin mit meiner Kamera quer durch
Deutschland gereist und ich habe mit der
Zeit sogar ein Team aufgebaut dass mir
bei den Videos hier hilft ein Team das
auch ein Büro braucht und mit diesem
Büro kam dann ein neues Studio seit
Oktober 2018 war ich in diesem Studio
hier daran erinnern sich bestimmt noch
einige von euch das war so ein bisschen
der nächste große Schritt mit fansigen
Animationen Traversen an den Decken und
einem richtigen Sound springfing und
seit letztem Jahr haben wir das ganze
noch mal gesteigert mit inzwischen ca 15
Leuten brauchten wir ein größeres Büro
und mit vielen verschiedenen Youtube
Formaten und sogar Livestreams brauchen
wir inzwischen auch ein größeres Set
dieses hier aber so geil dieses heads
für euch auch Aussehen für mich ist der
Blick immer mehr oder weniger gleich
geblieben ich gucke in die Röhre mein
Publikum beim Dreh war am Anfang niemand
und seit einiger Zeit ist es oft ein
Kameramann wie z.B Marian hallo oder
vielleicht auch mal ein Redakteur
letztens hatten wir bei einem ganz
großen Projekt über das ich leider noch
nicht reden darf ca 15 Leute am Set das
war schon mega groß für ein youtube-set
aber um ehrlich zu sein ich glaube da
geht noch ein bisschen mehr wenn ich
Vorträge halte oder bei Veranstaltungen
wieder IdeenExpo auf der Bühne stehe
dann merke ich immer wieder nur live ist
wirklich live
bin ich da etwas erkläre und die Leute
verstehen das dann sieht man das in den
Gesichtern da geht wirklich ein Licht
auf und wenn sie es nicht verstehen dann
merkt man das auch Live-Publikum ist da
super ehrlich super direkt und es ist
einfach eine andere Art und Weise Wissen
zu vermitteln und deswegen will ich
schon seit langer Zeit mal die Location
wechseln raus aus dem youtube-studio und
rauf auf die Bühne und genau dieser
Traum wird jetzt endlich wahr
wir haben acht Locations wie diese hier
gebucht und ich komme zu euch mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch in eine Stadt in
eurer Nähe denn wir haben uns angeschaut
wo die meisten Doktor Watson Zuschauer
sind und die Städte danach ausgewählt
und das aller geilste ist das hier wird
sogar eine internationale Tour denn ich
komme auch nach Österreich und in die
Schweiz Essen Köln Hamburg Berlin
Stuttgart München Wien Zürich aber
worüber will ich eigentlich reden nun es
muss ja schon etwas
wichtiges sein ich will ja kein reines
Entertainment machen mein Ziel ist es
immer mit allem was ich mache die
Menschen so ganz klein bisschen smarter
zu machen und es muss natürlich auch
typisch dr Watson sein deswegen habe ich
mir nichts weniger vorgenommen als die
wichtigsten Fragen unserer Zeit zu
beantworten es geht darum wie wir in der
Zukunft leben werden deswegen auch der
Titel der Show live aus der Zukunft wie
werden wir uns im Jahr 2050 fortbewegen
mit E-Autos Wasserstoffautos oder etwas
ganz anderem wie werden wir uns ernähren
vegetarisch von Insekten oder durch
Proteinpulver dass man aus Strom und
Luft herstellen kann werden wir auf die
Mars Leben und wenn ja wie können wir
dort überleben all das und noch viel
mehr werde ich beantworten auf die
typische Doktor Watson hat nur halt viel
länger und persönlicher also wenn ihr
Bock drauf habt mich live zu sehen dabei
so einiges über Wissenschaft und die
Zukunft zu erfahren und vielleicht sogar
am Ende ein Autogramm abzustauben dann
holt euch jetzt Tickets unter dr
watson.shop es gibt keine altersgr also
kommt gerne auch mit euren Eltern oder
Kindern bei uns ist alles
familienfreundlich und dann gibt es noch
eine extra Location ein besonderes Event
quasi das große Finale der Tour am 26
April 2024 dieses Event ist 10 mal
größer als alle anderen es ist zusammen
mit 1LIVE und mit anderen Creator Niklas
kolors Jakob von Breaking Lab Leonie
Schöler und Sina kürtz und dieses extra
große mega krasse und super geile Event
trägt den Titel meint blauen University
XXL wie Wissenschaft die Welt rette das
ist in Düsseldorf in der Mitsubishi
Electric Halle und es würde mich mega
freuen wenn wir uns auch da sehen denn
das ist noch mal eine andere Show mit
anderen Inhalten und halt auch mit mega
coolen anderen Creator an und auch dafür
kriegt ihr die Tickets unter dr
watson.shop ach ja und diese Tour heißt
natürlich nicht dass ich jetzt keine
Videos mehr mache oder nicht mehr gerne
vor der Kamera stehe das tue ich nach
wie vor sehr gerne aber ich habe das
Gefühl das ist noch mal ein anderer
Schritt für mich der nächste große
Schritt und ich habe da richtig Bock
drauf ich habe natürlich auch mega
Schiss davor so vor 500 oder sogar 5000
Leuten zu sprechen holy shit ich glaube
ich werde da mega nervös sein aber ich
glaube auch dass ich daran wachsen werde
und ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen
dass diese Live-Erfahrung wiederum die
Videos besser machen wird und es werden
übrigens auch während der Tour keine
Doktor Watson Videos ausfallen wenn ihr
also kein Ticket kaufen könnt dann
kriegt ihr genauso viel dr Watson wie
sonst auch wenn übrigens das Gefühl habt
ihr kriegt aktuell nicht immer jedes dr
Watson Video mit so wie mir das aktuell
viele schreiben dann lohnt es sich
vielleicht unsere neuen Newsletter zu
abonnieren keine Sorge wir Spam euch da
nicht zu und der ist natürlich kostenlos
dann informieren wir euch einmal im
Monat über die letzten vier Videos und
da erfahrt ihr auch als allererstes
zusammen mit den patience of patreon was
gerade bei dr Watson so abgeht wir
planen dann nämlich gerade noch ein paar
andere große Projekte könnte gut sein
dass es bald noch mal ein T-Shirt gibt
oder so und wenn wir da z.B weitere Tour
Stopps machen sollten werden wir das auf
jeden Fall auch dort als erstes
kommunizieren also sehen wir uns 2024
wenn ja dann schreibt mir gerne mal
unten in die Kommentare für welche Stadt
ihr Tickets gekauft habt schickt das
Video hier gerne an Freunde weiter die
vielleicht mit euch zusammen dahin gehen
wollen und schreibt gerne unten in die
Kommentare wenn ihr Fahrgemeinschaften
sucht oder anbietet es wäre mir sehr
lieb wenn diese Tour hier möglichst
wenig CO2 verursacht und die Forschung
hat gezeigt dass die Wege des Publikums
tatsächlich den größten CO2 Faktor
ausmachen danke an euch und bleibt
neugierig